country music's party of the year is
this weekend the Academy of Country
Music Awards will bring together some of
the biggest names in music Luke Bryan
and Dierks Bentley are both nominated
this year they have 35 ACM Award
nominations between them the pair has a
combined over 32 number one hits and 13
number-one country albums both returned
to the stage as co-hosts for the second
time in Las Vegas on morning yeah look
frylock turning did I'm standing
together they found that you bring in a
third co-host we get like really good
Beatles at so lets me do my back again
you must be doing something ya know is
it the chemical head is it the chemistry
between the two of you or what
well we've dirkson out we've got a lot
of history out there I mean we've been
on the same record label for I guess we
don't need to date to date us to to
Aegeus but we've been on the same record
label for for many years toured a lot
together who are a lot together back in
their early years the the formative
years of our career I think before we're
married exactly I'm a few years for you
this but we before you emerge the other
people yeah we have a TV marry or we
were married into we are yeah Cassie
careful now they'll use that against
them yeah but you guys have been
preparing for months for this right
yeah we've been we know email chains and
we've actually um I mean we've actually
huddled up around a couple of them we've
had formal meetings with CBS guys and
the guys that produce a show with none
of those CBS guys like when you have
formal meetings with them ah they come
in with briefcases that is it coming to
town and we take the banister on ahead
if I'm a lot of them food and about a
lot of wine a lot of drinks and then the
very end we talk about work for a little
they had this gold coin that was to me
when melted it down but you know make a
watch right guys when you watch that
debacle at the Oscars how they got it
wrong
was there a part of you that said we got
to do everything we can to make sure
that doesn't have notes or do you say
there's no way that can happen to
I can't imagine that happening to us but
you never know I mean last year when we
started the show off at the top I mean
it's just it's live there's going to
happen we try to involve some of our
buddies in the crowd last year to get
that yeah we had a series of like six we
don't three music artists that were
supposed to have a speaking role in the
audience and last year they only it kind
of got jumped and someone jumped the gun
a little bit and so we were kind of
flying by the seat of our pants yeah
like when we've realized that somebody
it wasn't one of the artists it was like
a camera guy missed his cue just cuz it
was a lot of moving parts and Dirks and
I were like okay well this is changing
oh that's really great but it was a weed
that's the beauty of live though yeah
everybody's nervous and it's thinking
about yeah I know yeah butterflies so
that's why we have a backstage bar set
up to help out jack level out then
you're both performing over the show -
right right have a we got good - or
thrive yeah I got a couple of perform as
three yeah now we have three I'm three
you three so what's the big question
going into this so big question going
and you know it's always um with me I
always like to look at the list of the
new performers that are getting then the
new young country artists that are
getting their first chance and I always
like worse well yeah I loves Meryl I
didn't in Dirk's um Dirk's has a song
out with Cole Swindell yes I said and
get a little plug-in from oh it's Cole's
kind of first big performance offering
from it and it's always fun seeing how
they handle their first big because when
you're a country artist and you get
these big-time television award moments
I mean it's a big it's a big thing for
your career you remember yours oh god
what do you remember about that I
remember a panic attack yeah but yeah I
just remember you know the just huge
amounts of anxiety and oh yeah there we
go but we the quick clap I know all
those people I'm her father
but we my first time ever doing major TV
was like bad 28 seconds to be on to
perform yeah and we had a plane to
tracks my drummer carried his drum out a
snare drum on stage and was pretending
to play drums we're all faking I looked
down there's Tim McGraw and Faith Hill
looking back up with us I was like wow
oh my god oh yeah
Chesney standing up Luke you know what I
think it's so cool about you your
speaking voice is kind of like your
singing voice uh-huh no but for many
people it's not though I love the way
you speak I'm not good I think
yeah accent is very thick you can't have
that Homer Powell all the way no we
should also it's probably gonna be a
very very big night for Keith Urban yes
he's yeah I mean Keith I mean I look at
Dirksen I we we kind of look at each
other about his career he just how he's
always song
he's the peace yeah I mean he could play
both here in so I'm not gonna tell he's
the best I think yeah I want to go with
what he's just so at playing the guitar
hard singing it oh yeah he just exists a
greater test Beachbody yeah guitar
playing he really is he's good he's ever
Omni I've never heard him play guitar in
any genre music Keith Hill is hands-down
the best you know Keith is on our label
insist he's so tasteful and every year
every year we our label does a private
event where all the artists come in and
play for everybody the works at the
label and Keith has done it for years
and until you just sit in a room with
him and a guitar and watch like it's I
mean we pry mean we pride ourselves on
being pretty good guitar players but
when you're around Keith and you see
like it's almost like there's 15 people
yeah I am the guitar and it's truly one
of the minutes it's a sight to behold
so like Shin Ji revin handsome yeah but
blows your mind when 2-cd revin Hanson
lesson how's your Pinterest going Luke
Bryan oh she called me I am talking
about it
that I'm sorry I see a difference of
interest I know I'm a Pinterest fan to
see I'm wanting this little fishing
cabin decorating either right wallpapers
fishing cabin is floral wallpaper for
that yeah because you start looking at a
cabin to build on a little fishing place
and then you like start seeing like
antiques like frames with fish and then
you see like the Billy bigmouth bass and
it takes you down this room I'm like oh
gosh this is a losses second X letters
anymore I got I'm running out on the
decorating together good planner Stadium
okay
so glad to have you guys here thank you
looking forward to the 52nd Academy of
Country Music Awards and they will air
what night Gail Sunday night at 8:00
7:00 central right here on CBS